I think possibly you can understand
George W Bush a little better in
relation to george herbert walker bush
if you consider the Henry the fourth and
the Henry the fifth place on the other
hand do I think there's the kind of
Majesty lurking and George W Bush that
came out like the son that had been
hidden beneath clouds I never saw
evidence of that so it's a kind of cute
analogy but ultimately it doesn't apply
and I think usually the people in
Shakespeare have more depth more
intensity I think than were ever allowed
at least to see if people in real life
because he goes inside their heads and
then he externalizes what what's inside
their heads an often majestic often
beautiful language